only minutes old this harp seal pup is
quick to fall in love with it's icy home
sweet home but ice melts in just 10 days
time mum will leave her behind and never
look back
the countdown begins ten put on at least
four pounds per day knife learn to swim
before the ice melts
eight don't panic there's no time to
waste 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
at first glance the Arctic feels
brutally devoid of life
though a select group of animals have
figured out a way to thrive
but the real force here works quietly
underfoot every winter ci starts small
and delicate then it grows over millions
of square miles how is it possible that
this freezer holds the key to our entire
planet like hello sea ice breathes life
into the Arctic every year in a cycle
that impacts the climate across the
globe this is the story from the edge of
the Canadian Arctic where it all starts
my name is Bertie Gregory Nova National
Geographic wildlife filmmaker everything
is at stake we're all waiting for the
big freeze
every year harp seals leave the rich
waters of the northern hudson bay and
join thousands of others migrating south
out of polar bear rent to their breeding
oasis
a massive ice floe in the Gulf of st.
Lawrence
[Music]
well it's hard to believe right now that
we're walking over the ocean
everywhere you look as far as you can
see his ice that's the reason I've got
this incredibly sexy and very
fashionable outfit on and a stick his
kids we want to make sure we don't fall
through a crack in the ice into
underneath us which is hundreds of feet
of freezing cold water but right now
we're looking for what is arguably the
cutest animal on the planet and I can
hear it
[Music]
this beautiful little animal hello is a
harp seal pup and it was born here on
the ice about four or five days ago
judging by its size and it's totally
helpless without mum right now
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
in a colony of thousands mum needs to
make sure she's not feeding the wrong
pup the kids this is what heart feels
are famous for that kiss is how the mom
and pup recognize each other that little
pups been waiting for this time and it's
really got to make the most of these
feeding sessions for kids it's only got
ten days with its mum after those ten
days the female's gonna stop suckling
the pup and she's gonna head north with
the males and that little puff is gonna
be abandoned with nothing to eat so it's
really got a roll of his fat reserves
now osos filling that pup and I found
something that's a little bit gross so
you see down here there's this blood
trail and it leads to this now this
looks like death but it's not this is
life this is the placenta and it's not
actually frozen yet that means that
somewhere around here is a newborn pup
there's literally just been born I mean
that would take less than an hour to
freeze so somewhere here is that little
pup
look there it is yeah how old is just a
few minutes old because yellow is and
you can still see this guy some biblical
cord attached you know compared to that
other putt we had which was only a few
days older yeah it's four or five days
older it shows just how fast they're
growing and this little pup has
definitely got some catching up to do
it's really cool to see such a young pup
but it's actually not a good thing this
one's for five days behind the rest and
these adults are already in a race
against time to raise their pups you
know before the ice breaks up so this
one has an extra big challenge ahead
[Music]
our changing climate is making early ice
breakups more and more common in five of
the past ten years bad ice meant the
colony struggled to raise pups in 2017
the ice broke up so early
that the entire year's pups drowned
overnight
[Music]
[Music]
so you can see what was once a giant
solid sheet is now all breaking up and
the ice is really on the move you can
see it here now it's the time for these
pups to learn to swim because seeing
these chunks are gonna get smaller and
smaller and smaller and and then yeah
that we forced the swim so it's swimming
time they got a yoke and that's exactly
what's on this mother's mind right now
it's real chunky monkey is so fat it's
unbelievable the change just in a few
days from that tiny little newborn now
to a big fat sausage so we're gonna hang
out and see if mom encourages it for its
first swimming lesson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody it's a guy yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because she's using her giant belly
there's a big swim float to help the pup
breathe you can see she's so protective
of it in the water anytime any other
adults come anywhere near she chases
them off so aggressively
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
terney Daggett it's sweet
[Music]
[Applause]
how incredible must it be to realize
you're actually built for the very
medium that was so daunting just minutes
ago
[Music]
now that the mother knows her pup has
the skills to survive the icebreaker
it's time for the hardest lesson of all
saying goodbye
[Music]
the male harp seals are now gathering
nearby ready to make with the females
okay get in
[Music]
it's time to the adults to join and head
to the north
[Music]
we've met some truly extraordinary
animals on this adventure their lives
governed by ticking clocks getting them
to run further fly faster or swim deeper
but the thing that ties them and us
together is the planets loudest ticking
clock the Arctic sea ice
the big fries used to give us millions
of square miles of sun reflecting
surface stabilizing the Earth's climate
over just the last 30 years we've lost
more than a third of that sea ice now
rather than reflecting the sun's heat
open water absorbs it and we are
witnessing its deadly effects
but there is hope and it lies with
harnessing clean energy using our land
more efficiently and reforesting saving
polar bears goes beyond just a nice
thing to do we're also saving ourselves
it really is in our hands whether we
want this place to exist in the future
because now is is really a turning point
do we let it go
do we band together to make sure that it
survives into the next century
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you